MALE SPEAKER: All right.
The man I'm here to
introduce and interview
really needs no
introduction as you can
tell by how full the room is.
But I'm going to
give him one anyway.
According to Wikipedia--
[LAUGHTER]
--professor Richard
Dawkins is a pathologist,
evolutionary
biologist, and writer.
He's also made a bunch
of documentary films.
Unlike President Obama,
Professor Dawkins
actually was born in Kenya.
[LAUGHTER]
His father was a civil servant
in the British Colonial Service
in what is modern day Malawi.
He studied zoology
at Oxford where,
after a stint at UC Berkeley,
he returned to teach.
During this period, he wrote
his first popular book,
"The Selfish Gene."
In this work, he argued strongly
that natural selection does not
occur at the species
population or individual level,
but rather at the
gene level itself.
In 1995, after several more
successful publications,
he was appointed to be
the Simonyi Professor
for Public Understanding
of Science, which
is a position created
by Charles Simonyi,
the man behind Microsoft Office
and the Hungarian notation they
use at Microsoft.
So all you ex-Microsoft
folks that are here.
And the position was created
with the express requirement
that Professor Dawkins
be its first holder.
He wrote many popular
science books, including
"Climbing Mount Improbable"
and "The Ancestor's Tale,"
in which he took
complicated concepts,
like the probabilities
involved in evolution
and the connection
of common ancestors
with humans and other
species, and made
them understandable
to the average reader.
One might say that he
organized some information
and made it more accessible.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD DAWKINS: That's
an in-group [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: So our
mission here at Google
is to organize the
world's information
and make it more
accessible and usable.
RICHARD DAWKINS:
Well, my mission
is to make morality
intelligently designed.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Professor
Dawkins started
to attract a lot more
widespread attention,
for better or for worse, with
the publication of "The God
Delusion" in 2006,
which was sort
of more of a full frontal
assault on religion.
In it, he argues that God
almost certainly does not
exist and gives many
explanations for why
he believes it's harmful
to hold such beliefs
and why they're not necessary to
explain, for example, morality.
He followed up this book with
"The Greatest Show on Earth,"
in which he gathered together
a massive amount of evidence
for evolution,
again, making it very
accessible to a lay reader.
I actually really,
really love this book.
I found it truly inspiring.
It really made it
clear to me just how
overwhelming the case is for
evolution by natural selection.
I remember finishing
the book on an airplane
and sitting there just
for the rest of the flight
just sort of in awe of
just how strong the case is
for evolution, how much
evidence we've gathered.
In 2006, he also founded The
Richard Dawkins Foundation
for Reason and Science, which
is a nonprofit organization
dedicated to promoting
scientific literacy
and secularism.
Specifically, he
wants to encourage
us to use our critical thinking
skills in our day-to-day lives
and allow secular views to
be more welcome in politics
and policy making.
Professor Dawkins retired
from the Simonyi Professorship
in 2008, since which he's
written a book directed
at children, "The Magic of
Reality-- How We Know What's
Really True," which,
I must add, is also
delightfully illustrated.
I've been saving this one.
I think it's about time I
let my daughter read it.
She's got a bunch of questions
that are answered directly
in that book.
So the book he's here to
promote is "Brief Candle
in the Dark-- My
Life in Science,"
which is the second part
of a two-volume memoir.
The first book, "An
Appetite for Wonder,"
is about his childhood,
youth, and time up
until he wrote
"The Selfish Gene."
So please join me in welcoming
Professor Richard Dawkins.
[APPLAUSE]
So I got all dressed up.
It's not our usual
attire, as you can see.
I wore my tie that
actually has species names
written in Latin on it.
[LAUGHTER]
And, as I was looking
through your book,
I noted that you had
a passage about how
the ties that you
do wear when you do
wear a tie are all designed
actually by your wife.
RICHARD DAWKINS: That is true.
She paints silk.
So every one of my ties
is a one-off unique tie.
I think she should
be selling them
for very large sums for
particular occasions
like golden weddings
to rich nerds from--
[LAUGHTER]
--never, otherwise,
wear a tie at all
as I can see looking
around the room.
[LAUGHTER]
Unfortunately, my ties are
all in the suitcase, which
is in the back of the car.
And I couldn't get it out.
So no tie today.
It's the only occasion on this
trip where there is no tie.
And that's in honor of Google.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So the story about
how you met your wife actually
kind of ties back to a bunch
of things that folks here--
RICHARD DAWKINS: Yes.
Perhaps I might read a
little passage on that.
Do you have the page number?
Here we are.
"This was 1992
when Douglas Adams
reached his 40th birthday.
And his party was memorable
for a particular reason.
It was there that he introduced
me to the actress, Lalla Ward,
whom he had known from
the days when "Doctor Who"
was at its wittiest because
he was the script editor.
And she and Tom Baker gave
added value to the wit
by their inventively ironic
playing of the two leading
roles.
At the birthday party, Lalla
was talking to Stephen Fry
when Douglas led me
over and introduced us.
Douglas and Stephen are
both absurdly much taller
than Lalla and me,
so it was natural
that we should find
ourselves facing
each other under a Gothic arch
formed by Douglas and Stephen
as they exchanged lofty
witticisms high above us.
Through the archway,
I shyly offered
to refill Lalla's glass.
And when I returned, we
rapidly reached agreement
that the party was too
noisy for conversation.
'I suppose by any faint chance,
it wouldn't just possibly be
a good idea to go out for a
quick meal and, of course,
return later.' We discreetly
slipped away and found
an Afghan restaurant
off the Marylebone Road.
That Lalla had read
"The Selfish Gene"
and watched my Christmas
Lectures was gratifying.
That she had read "The
Extended Phenotype" and Darwin,
as well, was too
good to be borne.
I subsequently discovered that,
in addition to Doctor Who's
companion, she had played
a beautiful Ophelia
to Derek Jacobi's "Hamlet"
in the BBC TV production
and was also a talented
and versatile artist,
published author,
and book Illustrator.
As I said, too good to be borne.
We didn't return to the party."
Miriam Rothschild is a very
distinguished biologist
and member of the immensely
wealthy Rothschild family.
And she's a great character.
She lives in a house
deep in a wood, which
looks like a kind of fairy tale
house covered with creepers.
You need a machete to find it.
And her garden consists
of wild weeds and grasses
breaking against
the house like waves
and going into the
French windows like waves
coming inside the house.
She has an annual
dragonfly party,
which is to celebrate
her conservation measures
of dragonflies around her lake.
It's a very large party with
about 80 people, I suppose.
And one year, she said, come
and sit by me, dear boy.
But, first, go and carve
me a slice of venison--
a very small slice, mind.
I'm a strict vegetarian.
[LAUGHTER]
And the scarf story
was that she's
the world authority on fleas.
And so Lalla was trying to
raise money for a charity
that she runs, which is
called Denville Hall.
It's an old people's
home for old actors.
And so I encouraged her
to paint an enormous silk
scarf, a gigantic silk scarf,
because Miriam Rothschild wears
silk scarves.
And she painted nine
different species of flea,
hugely magnified images
of fleas on this scarf.
And I sent it off
with a covering note
explaining about the charity.
And, eventually, Dame
Miriam wrote back and said,
"I shall keep the handkerchief,
but tell your wife
that she has sadly
underestimated
the penis of the male flea."
[LAUGHTER]
"As you know, it is
proportionately the largest
in the animal kingdom."
[LAUGHTER]
And she wrote a generous
check to the charity,
and accompanied it with her
own book on flea micro-anatomy,
inscribed to Lalla
with a note that said,
"See page 272 for
vagina of mole flea."
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So people
often perceive you
as being sort of
cold and calculated.
But, in this book, there are
a lot of stories that you have
that are very sentimental
and emotional.
In particular,
one that struck me
involved an experiment that
you were talking about,
having to do with
vision of the human eye.
I was wondering if you
might tell us about that.
RICHARD DAWKINS: I was
invited in the early 1990s
to give the Royal
Institution Christmas
Lectures for children.
This started out in
the 1820s, founded
by Michael Faraday, who
gave the lectures himself
on many occasions.
They've now become
five one-hour lectures
around Christmas
time every year.
And one scientist is
invited to give them.
Nowadays, they're televised.
It's quite an
intimidating thing.
The whole thing is very
highly choreographed.
There's a tradition
starting with Faraday
that you don't have
slides, or very few slides.
Instead, you call
the children out
to assist with demonstrations,
rather like conjurers do.
"In lecture five, I was talking
about a revealing difference
between two ways in which
the retinal image can move."
If you shut one eye, and
poke-- you don't even
need to shut the one.
Poke the other eye
with your finger.
You see the world move as
if there's an earthquake,
not surprising because the
retinal image is moving.
But if you swivel your eyes
around in their sockets using
the muscles that are
supposed for that purpose,
then you don't
see an earthquake.
The world appears to be still.
You're just looking at
a different part of it,
even though the retinal image is
moving in the same kind of way.
In one case, you
see an earthquake.
In the other case, you don't.
Well, there's a theory
about why this happens
due to some German
workers, which
is that when you give the
order-- when your brain gives
the order-- to the eye to
move around in the normal way,
swiveling in the socket, the
brain sends a copy of the order
to the perceiving
part of the brain
and tells the brain to
expect the world to move.
And so, since there's
no discrepancy
between the expected movement
and the observed movement,
the world appears to be still.
On the other hand, when
you poke your eyeball,
the copy doesn't go.
There's no copy that says,
expect the world to move.
So you do see it as if
there was an earthquake.
So that's the background.
"I pretended I was going
to demonstrate the effect
with a key experiment.
I would paralyze the
eyeball-moving muscles
with an injection.
Then, when the brain sent an
order to move the eyeball,
the eyeball would stay still,
but the copy of the instruction
would still be issued.
So the person would see
an apparent earthquake,
even though the
eyeball hadn't moved
and nor had the world,
the apparent movement
being the discrepancy between
the expected and actual
observed zero eye movement.
This being the Christmas
Lectures, the next thing to do
was to call for a volunteer."
[LAUGHTER]
"I produced a huge veterinary
hypodermic syringe,
fit to sedate a
rhinoceros and asked,
'Who would like to take part
in the experiment?' Normally,
the children at the Royal
Institution Lectures fall over
themselves in their eagerness
to assist in demonstrations.
Surely, nobody would
volunteer in this case.
And I was about to
reassure everyone
that it was only a joke when
one little girl of seven,
probably the youngest
in the audience,
hesitantly raised her hand.
It was my darling daughter,
Juliet, sitting shyly
by her mother.
I still choke up a
little at the memory
of her uncomprehending
loyalty and courage
in the face of the
monstrous hypodermic
that I was brandishing.
Is it irrelevant that she is
now a promising young doctor?"
MALE SPEAKER: So
one of the reasons
that that touched
me so much is I have
a 6 and 1/2 year old daughter.
And a lot of questions
are coming up
in how I raise her
around this age.
One of the things
that happened recently
was we're planning a trip
to Vietnam and Cambodia.
And one of the
things we want to see
is the Temple of Angkor Wat.
And when we went to
talk to her about this,
she didn't understand
what a temple was.
And, suddenly, my wife and
I were sort of on the spot.
How do we teach our
daughter about religion
without actually
teaching her religion,
because that seems important?
And I was wondering if you
had any thoughts on that.
RICHARD DAWKINS: It's a
very important distinction.
You can't get away from
teaching a child about religion
because the child would be
illiterate in the world today.
You couldn't understand
European history, for example,
unless you understand that many
of the wars in European history
have been between
Protestants and Catholics.
You can't understand
contemporary history
unless you understand
about Islam,
and Sunnis and Shias
and things like that.
You can't really take your
allusions in English literature
unless you know
biblical references.
So you've got to teach
children about religion.
But to indoctrinate a child
in a particular religion
and tell a child-- a
six-year-old child--
tell a six-year-old child,
you belong to this religion.
And, therefore, you believe in
this, this, and this and not
that, that, and that.
That's child abuse.
Tying a label around
a child's neck
as belonging to the same
religion as its parents
is child abuse.
Yet, we all do it.
We all quite happily--
we would never say,
this is a logical
Positivist child,
or this is an
Existentialist child.
[LAUGHTER]
This is a Hayekian
Monetarist child.
Nobody would dream
of saying that.
And, yet, we're quite happy
to talk about a Catholic child
or a Muslim child.
I read a story only a
week ago of a mother.
She had just given birth.
And the midwife held up
the baby to the mother
and said "What religion is he?"
And the mother said, "Isn't he
a little bit too young to know?"
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So also,
reading through the book,
I noticed a lot
of things actually
that made me think about
what we do here at Google.
One of the things
that came to mind
is the fact that,
here at Google,
we're sort of working at
the forefront of machine
translation.
And you had several anecdotes in
your book about the experiences
you've had trying to
translate your books and how--
RICHARD DAWKINS: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: --that
worked or not worked.
RICHARD DAWKINS: Well,
the first experience I had
was the German translation
of "The Selfish Gene."
I had a letter from
a woman in Germany
who said that the
translation was
so good that it was though
author and translator were
twin souls.
I thought that was
wonderful, so I looked up
the name of the German
translator, Karin de Souza
Ferreira.
Not exactly the
sort of name you'd
expect of a German
translator, but never mind.
I was immensely impressed.
And I told the story to a German
Swiss colleague, Hans Kummer,
a famous primatologist.
And I'd only got as far
as saying twin souls.
I didn't mention her name.
I just got as far as twin souls.
And he pointed his finger at
me and said Karin de Souza
Ferreira?
[LAUGHTER]
I thought that was a pretty
good recommendation, a kind
of independent recommendation.
I haven't always been so lucky.
When the Spanish translation
of "The God Delusion" came out,
I received three
independent letters
from Spanish-speaking people
who also spoke good English say,
"It was so bad, it was probably
done by Google Translate."
[LAUGHTER]
In other words, literal
translations of idioms.
But I must say that the Spanish
publishers manned up and agreed
to destroy that edition,
and withdraw it,
and commission an entirely new
translation, which I'm told
is very good.
So if you're interested
in the Spanish version,
get the more recent one.
MALE SPEAKER: So
also of interest
to some of the
folks here, I read
that for "The Selfish Gene,"
you actually wrote your own word
processor to write that?
RICHARD DAWKINS: Oh, that was
for "The Blind Watchmaker,"
yes.
I feel rather ashamed of
this because it really
is rediscovering the
wheel, not entirely.
I mean, I had an Apple
II computer at that time.
And the standard word
processor supplied by Apple
was called Apple Writer.
And there were no
lowercase letters.
It was all uppercase letters.
And uppercase was represented
by a reversal of color.
And there was no
proper wrap-around.
I mean, it was
really pretty poor.
It didn't wrap around properly.
So I did actually write
my own word processor,
which was called Scrivener.
And it was an immense
labor, as you could imagine.
I mean, you're all
professionals here.
You can knock it
off in a weekend.
But, for me, it took probably
the best part of a year,
and then I wrote
one book with it.
[LAUGHTER]
And that was that.
So I was addicted at that
time to computer programming.
I expect many people here
understand about the addiction.
And I would sort of
stay up all night,
and not eat, and not sleep,
and things like that.
MALE SPEAKER: It's not
uncommon amongst programmers
to think that you're creating a
tool you're going to use over,
and over, and over again
only to find that you only
used it the once.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD DAWKINS: Douglas Adams
has a very good satire on that.
He was well aware
of the syndrome.
MALE SPEAKER: So one of
the other things going on
in the conversations
that we have at
Google right now--
I know a lot of you
are talking about interviewing.
And one of the things that we've
been talking about as regards
interviewing is trying to
make the interview more blind.
So when we write our interview
feedback, not including things
like whether the candidate
was a woman or a man,
that sort of thing.
And what made me
think of this was
there's a passage
in the book where
you talk about the importance
of double-blind experiments.
RICHARD DAWKINS: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: And I
remember, as a grad student,
preparing papers to be reviewed
in a double-blind format, which
always just seems
like such a chore.
But it turned out, it's actually
really, really important.
And you touch on how important
double-blind evaluation is.
RICHARD DAWKINS: It's immensely
important in medical research
where it's so easy to be fooled.
And scientists now have to
be alive to the possibility
that they are being fooled by
what they want to discover.
They desperately
want to get a result.
And, with the best
will in the world,
it's very hard not
to be influenced.
So, I mean, I demonstrated
this in a television program
where we were looking at
water divining, dowsing.
And, since it was
television, we got
a lot of volunteers, people who
were life-long practitioners
of dowsing, water divining.
And they all were
absolutely confident
that they could do
it, but they'd never
been tested in double-blind
conditions before.
So, first of all, we
had a tent, and there
were lots of buckets of water.
And they were walking
over the buckets of water.
Or some of the buckets had
water, and some of them
didn't, of course.
And when they could see
the water, their hazel
twigs, or whatever it
was, dipped down exactly
as they should.
And it all went fine.
And then we did it blind.
So there was no clue as
to where the water was.
Even the experimenter
didn't know
where the water was because
he might inadvertently
have given the game away.
The person who had
laid out the buckets
did so and then left
and went 100 yards away
to the other side of
the tent so that he
couldn't give any clues.
And not a single one
of these dowsers--
from all over the
country, not a single one
scored above charts level.
They were devastated.
One of the women actually
broke down in tears.
She'd never been tested in
double-blind conditions before.
There was another
story, which I tell
in the book, of a
double-blind trial
of a diagnostic technique,
which is used by some quacks
to test the efficacy of
some certain substances.
I once actually did this myself.
I'd [INAUDIBLE] my neck,
and it was weekend,
so I couldn't go to
my ordinary doctor.
So I thought I'll go to an
alternative practitioner.
And the first thing she did was
to do a diagnostic test, which
was to kind of arm wrestle me.
I was lying on my back.
And she was testing the
strength of my arm against hers,
with and without a sealed
bottle of vitamin C on my chest.
And she showed, to
her satisfaction,
that when the sealed bottle
of vitamin C was on my chest,
I was weaker-- sorry,
I was stronger.
So when I sort of expressed
my skepticism, she said, yes!
See, it's a marvelous
vitamin, isn't it?
But then I told a
story in the book
of another very
similar test using
the same arm
wrestling technique,
again, testing a substance.
This time, it was whether
fructose or glucose
was put on your tongue,
whether it made you stronger.
And in double-blind
conditions, there
was, of course, no difference.
It didn't show any effect.
And the homeopath or whatever
he was who was doing the test
said, "You see?
This is why we don't
do double-blind trials.
They never work!"
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: I know
when I was preparing
the introduction to
this, for instance,
I was thinking about my
recollection of "The Greatest
Show on Earth," and having read
it on the plane and so forth.
But then when I actually went
looking through my books,
I found that it was
"The God Delusion" that
had the boarding pass in it.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD DAWKINS:
False memory syndrome.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
RICHARD DAWKINS: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And I had
somehow managed to-- I
mean, I was completely convinced
that what had not happened,
had happened.
And you mention that in
regards to recounting
an interaction with the
late Christopher Hitchens.
RICHARD DAWKINS:
Christopher Hitchens and I
were having a debate in London
with three religious types.
And so they were over there.
And we were here.
I was here.
Christopher was there.
And the philosopher,
A.C. Grayling, was there.
So we were very close together.
And, at one point, one of the
religious people, Rabbi Julia
Neuberger, said something
irritating or silly.
And Christopher Hitchens
interrupted and said, "How dare
you?
How dare you?"
Except that he didn't.
It's a false memory.
I remembered it
extremely clearly.
And I still remember
it extremely clearly.
[LAUGHTER]
I used it in a eulogy speech
that I gave after his death
in Melbourne.
I told the story.
And only quite recently
when checking up
to write the story
down in this book,
I looked at the YouTube
video of the event.
And it didn't happen.
What did happen was that Rabbi
Neuberger was interrupted.
She said something which he
did interrupt but much more
quietly.
And he didn't say, how dare you.
He said something
much more gentle.
He did say "how dare you"
about half an hour later
to a member of the audience
who asked a silly question.
And he said that, although
he didn't believe in God,
he thought of himself
as a Christian
because he was a moral person.
Christopher said,
"How dare you!"
[LAUGHTER]
Well, that's bad enough
that I had a false memory.
Then I was telling the
story of my false memory
to Anthony Grayling,
the philosopher,
because I thought he would
be interested in false memory
syndrome, which, indeed, he was.
But when I told him the
story, his jaw dropped.
And he said, but I had
exactly the same false memory.
[LAUGHTER]
And it occurred to me
that in courts of law,
for example, juries value
eyewitness testimony
above all other
kinds of evidence.
And imagine a lawyer
saying "I put it
to you, ladies and gentlemen of
the jury, that two university
professors both independently
had a false memory
of an event which took place
not two yards from where
they were sitting."
But there's a sequel to
the story, which actually
came after the book was
published and, therefore, is
not in the book.
The sequel to the story is
that a young woman, I told her
in a letter about what happened.
And she said that she had the
same false memory from having
watched the YouTube video.
So she had watched
the YouTube video,
and she was the third
person who had attached this
"how dare you" to the
response to Rabbi Neuberger,
instead of to the right place.
And I told her, well, go back
and look at the YouTube video
again.
She was actually
rather shattered by it.
Don't trust
eyewitness testimony.
And probably don't trust
my autobiography either,
for that matter.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So
one of the things
I wanted to talk about,
as regards "The Greatest
Show on Earth," in that
book, you compile experiment
after experiment validating
the claims and hypotheses
of evolutionary theory.
One of them that really stood
out was the Lenski experiments
where they actually chart
the evolution of-- I think
it's a bacterium--
RICHARD DAWKINS:
Bacterium, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: --over thousands
and thousands and thousands
of generations.
And they even stop
it at certain points,
set it aside, and show that they
can reproduce over and over.
And I remember thinking, wow,
this is such a slam dunk case.
But how do you--
something like that
is only convincing
to somebody who
has an understanding
of the fundamentals
of evolutionary theory.
When you're faced with somebody
making an argument like,
if we evolved from monkeys,
why are there still monkeys?
That belies a complete
lack of understanding
of even the fundamental--
the sort of stuff
that should be taught in
middle school, for instance.
RICHARD DAWKINS:
Well, it's just logic.
You don't need to
be taught that.
If Americans come
from Europeans,
why are there still Europeans?
[LAUGHTER]
Somebody said at
lunch, just before.
Yes, I mean, it's a
totally illogical--
what it stems from is the idea
that evolution is a ladder.
And we're at the
top of the ladder,
and then other apes
are just below us,
and then monkeys are
below that, and so on.
And so it's as though each
time a rung is climbed
of the ladder, the
one below is kicked
away or something of that sort.
There is no ladder.
It's a branching tree.
Every living creature,
every species
is the tip of a twig of its
own evolutionary history.
So there's no ladder.
There's no sense in which we
superseded monkeys or anything
like that.
Monkeys and we both superseded
the common ancestor,
which we share, some
20 million years ago.
It's as simple as that.
MALE SPEAKER: One
of the questions
that my daughter asked me, I
want to say a few months ago,
was, who was the first person?
And that's actually the
title of the second chapter
of your book, "The
Magic of Reality."
And I remember really
struggling to explain
to her the concept that there
really is no first person.
And I was explaining this to
a friend of mine and said,
well, my mom once dragged
me into a paint store
and showed me the samples
of paint where, on one end,
it was clearly yellow.
And, on the other end,
it was clearly green.
And then asked me, which
is first green sample?
But I wouldn't have
thought of that
to explain that to a child.
So how do you--
RICHARD DAWKINS:
Well, it's right.
I mean, there never
was a first person.
Every creature ever born
belonged to the same species
as its parents and its children.
So it's just that if you
put enough generations end
to end, if you start with
us today, and you go back,
and back, and back,
and back, and back--
if you go back 300 million
years, then you come to a fish.
But there never
was a transition.
There never was a sudden
transition from any one species
to any other.
The paint example is
a perfectly good one.
Another one that I use
in "The Magic of Reality"
is when we grow up,
we start as babies.
And we become toddlers.
And we become children.
And we become teenagers,
and then young adults,
and middle-aged, and then gaga.
[LAUGHTER]
But there never is
a sudden transition.
You don't go to bed
one night middle-aged
and then wake up next
morning and say, oh, I
seem to be old now.
It's a gradual, gradual change.
And exactly the same
is true of evolution.
It's a matter of
convenience that we
are capable of
separating or saying,
this definitely isn't a fish,
and this definitely is a fish.
All the intermediates
are not present.
But it's a category
mistake to say
that because we distinguish
humans from, say, monkeys,
there must have
been a first human.
There never was a first human.
It's just a gradual, gradual
transition everywhere you look.
MALE SPEAKER: So I'm going
to change tack a little bit
and talk more about
your experience
as a scientist, as a
teacher, and the experiences
that you had.
For example, in the book, you
talk a lot about your life
at Oxford.
And, as an American
who's not familiar
with that institition--
I mean, for example,
I was looking at the
history of the New College.
But by the New, they meant
1379 or something like that.
RICHARD DAWKINS: Well,
it was new in 1379.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
So there are a lot of
traditions, and formalities,
and so forth that took place
there that would seem foreign
and, dare I say, bizarre.
RICHARD DAWKINS: Well, it
seemed pretty bizarre to me,
as well, actually.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: And I
was just wondering
sort of what sort of influence
did that have on you?
You talk, for instance,
about the formal dessert
that you had where everybody
sits in a specific place,
and they pass
around [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD DAWKINS: Yeah.
Well, these are
rather quaint customs.
I sometimes suspect they're not
as ancient as you might think.
I mean, they might just go
back to the 19th century,
for all I know.
But each generation kind
of thinks they're ancient.
What can I say?
I mean, I had to preside over
this custom of formal dessert
where you pass around port
and nuts and snuff and things.
When I was Sub-Warden of New
College-- which everybody
becomes Sub-Warden at
some point-- and there
was a terrible evening
when I became aware
of some kind of
ominous rumbling.
And it was a very
distinguished professor
of philosophy, Michael Dummett.
And he was saying, "I've never
been so insulted in my life.
You have the most
atrocious manners.
You must be an Etonian.
Etonian means somebody who
comes from Eton College, which
is Britain's most prestigious
and most expensive
private school.
[LAUGHTER]
And the target of his
ire was Robin Lane Fox
who was a fellow
in ancient history.
Robin was hopping with
anxiety and saying, "But what
have I done?
What have I done?"
And I couldn't work
out what it was.
But I saw to it
in my hostly role
that they were seated as far as
possible away from each other.
And then, the next
day, I discovered
what the trouble was.
It had boiled up from
lunchtime the previous day.
And there was some trivial
little minor dispute
over who should sit where
or something like that.
And Professor Dummett
had harbored this rancor
throughout the rest of the day.
And it had bubbled up to the
surface until, by the evening,
it boiled over at dessert.
But then, three days
later, he approached
Robin Lane Fox and
most graciously
apologized and said there
was nobody in the college
that he would less
wish to insult.
So it all ended up all right.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: And while
you were at Oxford,
there was a period of time
when your uncle was also
a fellow at Oxford.
RICHARD DAWKINS: Yes, my
father's youngest brother,
my Uncle Collier.
He was a wonderful character.
One nice story about him was
that he came back from London
on the last train to Oxford.
And the car park at
the railway station
had an arm that you had to put
a coin in the slot in order
to release your car.
And, at midnight,
the arm had broken.
And so the entire
car park was trapped.
Nobody could get out.
My Uncle Collier
was on his bike,
so it wasn't a problem to him.
But showing supreme
altruism, he broke the arm,
and marched up to the
station master's office,
plunked it outside the
station master's office
with a note giving
his name and address
and saying exactly
why he'd done it.
And he was prosecuted and fined
for this public-spirited act.
And then, many years
later after his death,
actually, I happened to be going
to visit a rather old professor
of physics, Nicholas Kurti.
And when he heard my
name, he said, "Dawkins?
Are you any relation
of the man who
broke the arm at the station?"
[LAUGHTER]
So I said, "Well, yes.
I'm his nephew.
And he said, "Come.
Let me shake your hand.
Your uncle was a hero."
[LAUGHTER]
I think the other story
you were thinking of
is he was an expert
in statistics.
He taught statistics
as well as forestry.
So I used to take my own pupils
and ask him to tutor them
in statistics.
I didn't take them.
I mean, I went and saw
him to ask if we would
tutor my pupils in statistics.
And I was doing that
one time in his office.
And I was describing
this young man.
I was saying things like, well,
he's a bit lazy, but he's OK.
And you'll have to look after
him, make sure he works,
and so on.
And I noticed that my
uncle was taking notes.
He wasn't taking
notes in English.
This was the Department of
Forestry, the Imperial Forestry
Institute at Oxford, which is
filled with old colonial types
from all over Africa.
And so I said, well, that's
very confidential of you,
taking notes in Swahili.
And he said, "Swahili?
Good god, no.
Everyone in this
department speaks Swahili.
This is Acholi."
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: One of my other
favorite parts in the book
are, basically,
the parts where you
talk about all the other
books that you've worked with.
There are a lot of pictures
of colleagues and so forth.
You talk about the debates and
the preferred mutual tutorials
that you've done
with other folks.
Who would you say
that you've worked
with in that capacity that's
really had the biggest
influence on you?
RICHARD DAWKINS: I like the
idea of the mutual tutorial.
I find that the
debate format is not
an attractive one,
the format where
you have 10 minutes
for the proposition,
10 minutes for the opposition,
three minutes for rebuttal,
three minutes for
rebuttal, and then a vote.
I don't think that's the
way you get at the truth.
I like the mutual tutorial
where you have a conversation.
And it doesn't have
to be adversarial.
Sometimes a conversation can
be between people who pretty
much agree with each other.
I suppose the best one
for me was Steven Pinker,
the psychologist and linguist.
And perhaps it was
the one that gave me
the idea for the
mutual tutorial.
We had an on-stage conversation
in a London theater,
about 2,000 people.
It was a very large audience.
And it went very well.
And we learned a
lot from each other.
You sort of raise each other's
game in a funny kind of way.
And precisely because
you're not disagreeing,
you're actually learning
from each other.
The BBC got to hear
of this, and they
thought it might be
fun to reprise it
on television that evening.
So they asked us
would we agree to go
and have a shortened version of
our conversation on television.
We said yes.
And then the woman
producing it phoned me
up to plan the program.
And she said, "Tell me.
What's the nature of your
disagreement with Dr. Pinker?"
And I said, "Well, I
don't think we really
got much of a disagreement.
We seem to agree
about most things."
And she said, "No disagreement?
No disagreement?"
She promptly cancelled
the whole thing.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So as we're getting toward
the end of our time,
I wanted to take a
couple of questions
off of our submitted
questions list.
The top one we have
right now says,
"You must have rebutted
them all by now,
so I'd be curious to know
what, in your opinion,
are the best arguments out
there against evolution
and the nonexistence of deities?
Which do you find the
hardest to rebut?"
RICHARD DAWKINS: Those are
two quite different questions,
by the way.
There is no decent
rebuttal of evolution.
And there is no decent
argument in favor
of the existence of deities.
So if I attempt to answer that
question, I'm not in any sense
admitting that there is a
good argument because I once
made the mistake of saying the
best argument I could think
of for the existence of a God
would be a deistic God who
had something to do with the
fine-tuning of the universe.
I think that is probably
the best argument around.
It's still a very,
very bad argument,
but it's the best one going.
But when I said that once in
a debate actually with a man
called John Lennox, two days
later he was up in Scotland
giving a lecture on his own.
And he more or less announced
that I had become a deist--
[LAUGHTER]
--simply because I had said
out of all the bad arguments,
this is the least bad.
And I've since met this
problem over and over again.
That if you say x is
bad, but y is worse,
people will think you're
condoning x or somehow saying
that x is a good thing.
So I think the best argument
for the existence of a god
is the fine-tuning argument.
But it's still a very,
very poor argument
because you still
have left unexplained
where the fine tuner came from.
The best argument
against evolution?
There isn't one.
I mean, there's just
no argument against it.
I mean, there are reasons
why people don't get it,
which is a different question.
There are reasons why
people don't get it,
such as that the time scale
involved is so huge that people
find it difficult to
grasp how long a time has
been available for the
changes we're talking about.
In a way, Darwin
had it right when
he pointed to things
like dogs and pigeons
where we know how
long it's taken.
And actually,
Lenski's bacteria too,
but Darwin didn't
know that, of course.
It hasn't taken very long to
turn a wolf into a Pekingese.
And when you think
that that's only
taken a matter of
centuries, and then you
think that to turn
a fish into a mammal
has taken not just centuries but
hundreds of millions of years.
And if you extrapolate
the amount of change
from wolf to Pekingese
and multiply it
by the number of centuries there
have been in 300 million years,
you get an idea of how you
will not grasp evolution
unless you can somehow get your
mind around these immensities
of time.
MALE SPEAKER: It seems like
sort of the same problems
that we face, which is
obviously not as big of a deal,
in terms of our
society and so forth,
of getting people
to understand things
like quantum mechanics
and general relativity
that our brains are
designed to-- are designed?
[LAUGHTER]
--where everything is
middle of the road, and--
RICHARD DAWKINS: I think
the word "designed" is fine.
It's just that it's not
designed by an intelligence.
I mean, I think the
remarkable thing
is that brains which were
designed by natural selection
to survive on the African
savannah as hunter gatherers,
and to get a mate,
and rear a child,
and avoid being eaten by
lions, fairly simple problems
compared to quantum
theory or relativity.
And yet, those very same brains
have the emergent property
that they can understand
quantum theory.
I can't, but some people can.
[LAUGHTER]
And it makes me proud to be
a member of the species homo
sapiens.
MALE SPEAKER: I'll take
one more off of our list
here, which is, where do you
see the world 10 years from now,
in terms of belief in myths
versus belief in science?
It seems that the overall
trends are positive for science
and negative for myth worldwide.
There is also what seems to
be a backlash, for example,
the rise of radical Islam
and the anthropogenic global
warming denial by
many in the US.
RICHARD DAWKINS: Yes.
I mean, I think if you look
on the broad sweep of history,
things are going in
the right direction.
If you take poll data in America
and in western and northern
Europe, things are going
in the right direction.
In Britain, for
example, the number
of people who ticked the
Christian box in the 2001
census was, I think, 73%.
And, in the 2011
census, it was 54%.
And my British foundation,
The Richard Dawkins Foundation
for Reason and Science,
which, by the way,
is much more
flourishing in America
and is doing more sorts of
active things in America--
please join The Richard
Dawkins Foundation for Reason
and Science in America.
But the British foundation did
a further survey of the people
who ticked the Christian
box in the 2011 census
and found that actually,
although it's still 54% ticked
the Christian box, who actually
asked them supplementary
questions, like, "Is Jesus
your Lord and Savior?"
and, "Can you pick out
of this list of four,
what is the first book
of the "New Testament?"
The number dropped
dramatically below that 54%.
I mean, scarcely any
of them could really
claim to be proper Christians.
In America, the number of people
who subscribe to any religion,
20% don't.
There are 20% of the
American electorate now
who don't subscribe to any
religion according to polls.
And that's a very high figure.
It compares favorably with
any particular religion.
So I think things are moving
in the right direction
but with dips.
It's a sawtooth rather
than a gradual trend.
And, as you say, the
rise of radical Islam
is a negative trend,
which may take
a bit longer to get rid of.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So, with that, let's
thank our speaker.
He's going to be signing books.
Just to remind you, we won't
be personalizing them just
because we won't have time.
But, yeah, let's
thank our speaker.
[APPLAUSE]